.
>> Tucker: HERE IS AN AMAZING
STORY.
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS,
YOU TRUST IF YOU HAVE KIDS.
ISSUED NEW GUIDANCE ON OBESITY.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER IN LIGHT OF
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS NEW GUIDELINE FOR
CHILDHOOD OBESITY.
ANYONE WHO TRIED TO LOSE WEIGHT,
STOP EATING SUGARY FOOD, THAT IS
NOT THE GUIDANCE, THEY ARE
SAYING KIDS SHOULD TAKE WEIGHT
LOSS MEDICATION AND POTENTIALLY
UNDERGO SURGERY FOR CHILDREN.
DR. MARC SIEGELIN JOINS US.
>> 15 MILLION CHILDREN ARE
OBESE, THAT WAS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND THE GUIDELINES READ
LIKE PANIC.
CLINICAL PRACTICE, I DON'T
FOLLOW CLINICAL PRACTICE
GUIDELINES, I DON'T DOCTOR BY
THE NUMBERS.
I LISTEN TO THE PATIENT.
I DON'T FAT SHAME, I LISTEN TO
THEIR CONCERNS, ARE YOU
DEPRESSED, WHY ARE YOU EATING SO
MUCH?
GUESS WHAT THE PANDEMIC DID?
TOOK KIDS AWAY FROM EXERCISE
PROGRAMS.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENS, THEY ARE
BURGEONING IN WEIGHT, WHAT DO
THEY DO NOW?
KNEE JERK A SOLUTION, GIVE THEM
A PILL, THAT DOESN'T WORK,
SURGERY MIGHT HAVE
LONG-COMPLICATIONS TO IT.
I HAVE A PRESCRIPTION, I WANT TO
GO BACK TO THE BEGINNING.
I HAVE MY OWN GUIDELINES.
YOU INTRODUCE VEGETABLES TO YOUR
DIET AND YOUR KID'S DIET.
GO ON A WALK AND TAKE YOUR KID
ON A WALK.
YOU HAVE THEM EXERCISE, RIDE A
BIKE AND HAVE THEM RIDE A BIKE
AND CHALLENGE THEM, YOU SAY,
WATCH TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT AND
SEE IF IT CHALLENGES YOUR BRAIN.
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: GETTING RID OF PIZZA
AND OREOS, SPEAKING TO MYSELF, I
DO LOVE, THAT GOES ALONG WITH
THAT.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> Tucker: PIZ